Donald Trump has a real problem with
black people even though he recently
said he would win the black vote he's
actually polling somewhere between one
and two percent statistically zero in
some individual states a recent poll in
Ohio had Trump polling zero now Louis
that doesn't mean no black people are
voting for Trump in Ohio what it means
is statistically it didn't even make it
to one percent in the poll and that's
bad enough yeah I'm not sure how it'll
happen but I'm hoping at some point
he'll reach a negative 1 or 2 percent
with the black vote
so Trump decides to go after the black
vote he's going to court the black vote
and like most things in the Donald Trump
campaign he seems to end up doing the
opposite of what's logical he decided to
go make an appeal to the black vote in
front of yet another mostly white crowd
and just said untruth after untruth
about black people
I don't know that Trump said anything
accurate about black people in this
speech other than the fact that he
seemed to acknowledge them as black
people right he seems to be talking
about them as if they are part of
homosapiens that's the only relatively
accurate thing in the entire discussion
here I will play the clip for you this
is Trump speaking in Dimondale Michigan
which is ninety six point four percent
white and he made a horribly misinformed
appeal to black people take a look what
do you have to lose by trying something
new like Trump what do you have to
right
[Applause]
good luck with it I say it again what do
you have to lose look why do you have to
lose you're living in poverty your
schools are no good
you have no jobs 58% of your youth is
unemployed right what the hell do you
have to lose
he then doubled down on the insane going
on the Jeanine Pirro show on Fox News
which we could do a couple hours on that
show alone I mean that that show is
insane so he goes on one of the most
heinous and depraved shows on one of the
most heinous and depraved networks and
it's totally Looney Tunes he said black
people have no education either take a
listen gentlemen you know is in my
speech and I really thought of just was
reading the statistics where you have 40
percent that are living in poverty 58
percent of the of the students I mean
the young people they can't get jobs and
you know it's just like a total
catastrophe the unemployment rates
everything is bad no health care no
education no anything
no anything that poverty is unbelievable
and then I said hey wait a minute
loads of me what do you have to lose I
can't do worse you can't do any worse
than what these people have been doing
and I will do better and actually said
that if you vote for me the next time in
four years I'll get 95% of your vote
because you see such a big improvement
when you say you're living in poverty
you're clearly implying are saying that
poverty is something that afflicts most
or a majority of the group in this
particular case black Americans
otherwise why would you say it that way
yes black Americans have a higher than
average poverty rate around a quarter
compared to a 10% overall but he's
saying that yeah basically poverty is
just it's a most black people or poor so
why not vote for me he said black people
are sending kids to failing schools as
if that's the fault of black people that
schools and disproportionately black
areas have problems it in fact Trump
part of his platform is to take away
federal funding from education which
would only make those so-called black
schools be even worse off yeah well it's
part of the whole Donald Trump thing
that I can improve everything yeah
everything will be better under me and
just telling people that they're
completely destitute
and have absolutely nothing to lose
doesn't seem like the best strategy when
you say you have no jobs you're clearly
implying or saying that unemployment is
something that afflicts most or a
majority of black Americans otherwise
again why would you say it and yes
unemployment is higher among black
Americans as it is among Hispanic
Americans in terms of black Americans
it's roughly double the national
unemployment rate but it seems Jason
like Donald Trump doesn't know that most
black people are not poor and most black
people have jobs I mean it's like a
caricature of the population that he
that he seems to be focusing on here
well I guess when you say your message
is well it just can't get any worse try
me I mean that pretty much does it all
to me right there you have to sort of
outline a caricature of how things are
if your message is I can't possibly be
worse than where things are right now
because that's you're you're depending
on things being a disaster in order for
that to appeal to anybody yeah it's and
certainly this is a disastrous place
we're in right now but who really thinks
that Donald Trump is going to turn
things around
for black people as he says if you
believe Trump statistics the next
question becomes how will Trump's
policies on for example health care or
funding for education or his view on
voting rights
none of those positions will at all help
the black American community Trump says
well we need to create job opportunities
I agree with that the problem is his
policies won't actually do that let me
say a quick word about today's sponsor
blue apron I've now cooked blue apron
meals twice and I absolutely love it
basically the way it works is you get
the fresh ingredients for three meals
sent to you it's all delivered in a cold
pack it is all fresh it is all segmented
and portions so that you don't have
waste and it is sourced closer to where
you live than the ingredients you might
buy in a local grocery store and as you
know Louis I'm a big fan of cooking
different items but it's very easy for
me when I have to you know figure out
what to buy at the grocery store I'm
busy I just go back to the classic six
or seven rest
that I rotate and blue apron is awesome
because they do not repeat any recipes
for an entire year they send you the
ingredients and you cook stuff you would
probably never think to cook I made a
pizza for example I made a pasta dish
that I had never even heard of never
mind would ever consider making so it is
really really cool way to cook fresh not
waste food and really mix up what it is
that you are eating
and viewers of the show can get three
free meals if you go to blue apron
dot-com slash Pakman and you get free
shipping as well some of the meals
available in August summer vegetable and
quinoa Bowl Louis is a huge fan of
quinoa with fairy tale eggplants
shishito peppers and corn also chicken
Tinga tacos with summer squash and
tomato salsa get three meals free with
free shipping at blue apron dot-com
slash Pakman it's the best